faut se rendre compte toute la journée
après un an et les blogueurs ils en
remettent une couche tout le temps tout
le temps et il a un écarté des beaux et
Ilan boycotté et ilanne si c'est
insupportable à vivre c'est
insupportable parce que tout le temps
dans la sauce pour cette histoire de
merde où j'ai pas mérité ça et les gens
me disent Ilan tu devrais te faire tout
petit mais non je vais me faire tout
petit si j'ai fait quelque chose vous
avez ma parole d'homme sur la tête de
mes grands-parents que si j'avais fait
quelque chose j'aurais coupé tous les
réseaux je me fais tout petit comme ça
si un jour il y a un problème bon bah ça
fera pas de bruit mais je vais pas me
faire tout petit parce que j'ai rien
fait donc s'il faut que je le répète
pendant 5 ans pendant 10 ans pendant 20
ans je le répéterai pendant 20 ans je
n'ai rien fait de ces histoires de merde
et c'est une vérité et aujourd'hui le
problème c'est que quand quelqu'un dit
et bah tu as fait Ilan est-ce que tu as
fait tentative de suicide
je vais vous dire la vérité j'ai eu un
moment j'ai eu un vrai vrai coup de mou
ouais j'ai eu un vrai coup de mou
sur une accumulation sur une
accumulation c'est un moment donné
je peux aller bien 5 heures dans la
journée mais je vais voir une seule
petite insulte ça va me
ça va me tuer parce qu'en fait c'est pas
celle-là c'est tout ce qu'il y a eu
avant moi je vais te dire je peux
résumer ton histoire et je rejoins
Géraldine maillet on le voit un tous
ceux qui font de la télé-réalité qui
font après des réseaux sociaux on les
voit ce sont les plus malheureux du
monde et c'est vrai que je vous dis
c'est un fléau incroyable je le redis
pour moi c'est le plus grand fléau du
moment pour les pour les jeunes c'est
ils finissent tous mal ils sont tous
malheureux j'en connais pas un qui est
heureux à un moment donné quoi qu'il
arrive ils sont malheureux ils sont dans
le système c'est ça les bras et et je te
le dis mais Géraldine moi que tu sortes
un peu de ces conneries limite c'est
peut-être une bonne nouvelle parce que
je te dis c'est un drame ça et on en
parlait voilà on voit il y a plein de
gens qui disent voilà les réseaux
sociaux en fait
c'est que ça je suis désolé voilà ouais
mais faut pas écouter les rumeurs c'est
à dire qu'en calque sur les il y a
beaucoup de choses qui se disent
les amis les blogueurs
aujourd'hui deux éventuellement votre
malheur vous voyez ce que je veux dire
bah en fait le système est complètement
perversé complètement vicieux en fait
c'est la c'est la fin du système en fait
donc en fait c'est qui la vérité avec
tout ce que j'ai vécu hein et je pense
que je suis une personne bien placé pour
dire ce qui est bon ou pas sur la télé
oui il y a eu des drames oui il y a eu
des choses très graves et j'en suis la
preuve mais il y a aussi du bon
vous savez non mais je suis à prendre
que la moitié il y a aussi du bon moi je
vous dis la vérité la production avec
laquelle j'ai le plus travaillé
ils ont aussi intervenu dans mon
éducation qui c'est qui la production
moi j'ai beaucoup de bossé avec Banijay
c'est une belle boîte et il faut savoir
une chose c'est que je vous le dis quand
j'ai commencé j'avais 23 ans je parlais
mal toi
mais pour vous dire un exemple non parce
que c'est important
non mais c'est important moi quand j'ai
commencé à thé j'ai pas envie de dire je
parlais mal je pouvais dire des insultes
des trucs mais croyez pas qu'on est
parcadré moi combien de fois on est même
dire Ilan ça ici il y a pas de ça tu
dois parler correctement tu dois
respecter tu dois faire ci faut pas
croire qu'on est une solution je l'aime
pour que ça s'arrête on est leurs
enfants
marie-toi je te promets que ça va
s'arrêter
à 200 m il y a pas de problème non parce
que la vérité c'est que pour toi Daniel
Moreau
[Rires]
on se
calme hein
en fait non c'est qu'il faut comprendre
c'est pour vous dire faut et c'est
vraiment important faut pas écouter
juste les rumeurs en fait si quelqu'un
parle d'une chose sans preuve il faut
pas l'écouter parce que oui il y a du
vrai mais il y a aussi beaucoup
c'est vraiment c'est ça c'est la télé
merci